so perception is everything and you can
elevate yours at las vegas newest
immersive experience and museum on the
strip rocky is live at perception
studying the universal man hi rocky
hi youtube yes the universal man let's
talk to robert what does that mean who
is that so leonardo da vinci was really
the first true renaissance man
he's known very much as a painter having
two of the most famous paintings in the
world but his really true genius was
inventing you know the precursor to
flying whether it was the helicopter the
airplane the parachute and he was
actually the first one to kind of
suggest the idea of us uh breathing
underwater wow what i love about these
immersive experiences it's not only a
vibe and really interesting and
stimulating but you're learning
something too so tell us about this
particular exhibit and why it's so
special so we highlight all of his great
accomplishments and i think the
cameraman now is in the grand salon and
those are all of his limited images
brought to life so it showcased all the
great drawings it did all he dissected
the human heart it shows all of his
veins running through his body so he was
the first one to do that and he had to
do this defying the church so he
actually had to write instead of light
left to right right to left so he really
did it when it was times people were
being persecuted for going against the
church this is deep you guys so let's
walk into because there's three rooms in
this entire exhibit so let's walk into
this next room introduce us to where we
are now this is
incredible painted with light as you can
see it's
2.5 megapixels
which is the distance between the
megapixels and this is the last supper
so you can see it it formulates all
these images and this is kind of the
final image it culminates in the last
supper and what's interesting about this
is the technology right this is not just
your average you know walk through
digital museum there's some real it gets
it's almost like a disco in here yeah so
it's uh exactly right it's 12.1 dolby
versus 5.1 so typical movie theater is
5.1 so the sound marries with the images
so as you're walking through you can
really feel the emotional changes of all
the images that's amazing and let's have
let's have your guy go ahead and start
it up so you can get a feel of those
lights wow this is incredible in here so
obviously you can walk through bring
your family sit down and really take it
all in and then visit the gift shop and
you have officially visited the very
first digital museum digital art museum
on the strip right yeah that is correct
we are the first home we're here for a
long time and we hope to bring a lot of
great entertainment to las vegas
beautiful so this exhibit itself the
leonardo exhibit is temporary right yeah
it's our first show it'll run for six to
nine months and we've already planned
our second and third show okay you guys
gotta come down we are on the strip i'll
send it back to you rocky that is a trip
just watching it on the tv screen that's
amazing trying to figure out where you
were yeah
she's immersed in it we'll check back in
with you later on in the hour thank you
rocky all right moving